mer
[Music]
ain't worried about dicks
bro I ain't scared of that kid he ain't
in charge of me H bro you smoke bare man
and gotten away with it yeah let him
come try me
meanwhile I'll be making stacks of lizes
all
day some mad Stacks
bro yeah yeah who let me make some of
that you want to make some Mula
keep your head down and get your
education bro you ain't about to join
role when you can be a 30ty businessman
making legit peas there ain't no way I'm
going to make peas like that being legit
are you dumb
bro you can make more than
this you ain't about to join Road I can
promise you that
om I don't know man my sick of mths
could help us
out what the are you talking about then
you just want to bring another brother
down or something what do you mean you
seem to be pressed that Omar a poor
brown man can make a big life whil right
here trapping like some white hood rat
you know ain't like that your most
family I don't care if you're black
white brown pink purple whatever I
always want the best of my Bros are we
really Bros like that though
what yeah we're
boys we ain't never going to be family
not whilst you ging people like me down
like we're animals or something so what
you think that's white people the same
yeah you think all we do is kill black
people is that how you think I am
act you know I ain't like
that my brother
a
yeah I guess we'll
see we're all
family hello a you must be smoking some
of your own supplier cuz you know
Lenny's
family I mean I'm about to call the guy
Abdullah or
something yeah I
know Lenny's our
boy
right I'll always Rong with you
man no matter what
stuck
up what that neighbor what no Uncle
George No
George Uncle George just leave shut your
mouth now you've caused enough trouble
what I think you know what this is about
mate I know who you are and let's just
say I ain't a fan of your work so either
say what you got to say or you leave oh
I've got something to say right keep
yourself and your cult religion away
from my
family so you're related to Jackie yeah
she's my sister and AR's my niece now I
don't know if you're familiar with the
concept of having a family to care for
but let me tell you this Omar I will die
for mine and I will kill anyone who
messes with him I don't know what you
think I did to your sister or your niece
but if you're trying to threaten me or
something oh it ain't a threat it's a
warning I'm shaking my boots you taking
the you need to back off man if anything
it's your sister that's been harassing
me since I got here yeah right and all
she deserves to live in peace in her own
home in her own
country I guess it runs in the family
here stay away from my family or next
time I come it won't be for a chat I
could mess you up just for the racist
stuff that you've said online you know
what I have a feeling that we're going
to meet again and like this beautiful
book says Allah is with those who have
patience and you know what George I'm a
very patient guy you know what pisses me
off about you
people you come here you want to live in
Britain but you don't respect the
British
people you just want to inflict your
backwards ideology on any parod you bump
into try and convert anyone you
find honestly you're like a pack of
zombies just cheering and Goring people
well let me tell you this Omar you won't
get to my family cuz I'll be standing
right in front of them and I always aim
for the Ed
any
moves nothing
yet you sure he's in there
he's
inside I got
this I want to see his
face what's the deal with is
you I ain't seen Idris since Omar showed
his mug they're
de he's on that Muslim Flex in it
growing that
beard you got to give respect where it's
due he cleaned himself up
he was rad once what's the deal between
you guys
anyway does it matter yeah it
does when we ride I need to know if it's
going to be a problem
harmless used to roll with my son back
in the
day
Tyler
Dyan Big Boy Bell on him
when he needed him most sh I'm surprised
you ain't done nothing to him yet that
was a long time
ago I was canned myself at the
time and when I broke
loose Janet had my hands tied my hands
ain't tied Omar is off limits yeah
almost off limits J's off limits the you
have with Jam is history we part up on a
job J belongs to us now he's rep
he's finished on world like it should
be
listen I want you and Tina to roll up on
Idris T was right job's too big for him
he's going to be in it I'm going to test
Idris
first see what he's
got how
I'm going to line him up for a
collect make sure you give it to him
empty to see what he
does and he solves the
problem you know what ain't down with
Jam or this you
there he
comes
sneaky deal with
this I'm
hungry AR we
all for
[Music]
is that really
you how did you even know it was me you
can't even see my face have your
mother's eye you know thanks Anie it's
been a long time Amir I know I guess I
just needed some time but I'm here now
going to cook Omar some dinner Omar how
is he
Omar's well Omar he's a good man well I
am proud of him like he's my own son
that's really nice Ali and I'm sure he
thinks of you too like your family very
happy back here please shop I'll give
you a family discount no it's okay B
it's only 5% off
well you have to rob a bank
yeah actually mind telling me where the
nearest one
is it's
me I said Salam oh
sorry Salam how are you um fine
what's wrong now
H it's nothing just my five wanted to
talk to me of something typical I knew
this would happen look homar this is my
job all right I see this happen all the
time these people they go for someone
religious someone with influence someone
with links someone they can use for
their own Advantage they've always got
something up their
sleeve look the best thing to do right
now ignore them ignore any calls any
offers any money anything even a
friendly chat over a morning coffee
isn't as simple with them I wasn't going
to right by the way what the hell is
George from the mlba doing here you saw
him yeah coming out of your block he
asked me if I was off to commit Grand
robbery what does he live here no just
his
sister who's his sister
no I don't know I just found out
yesterday
when when
what actually never
mind um no when what no it's fine it's
fine om tell me right
now where's your
mom mom someone at the door for you
who the hell are you listen here Jackie
all right I've had enough of your
current ambushes against my brother it's
one thing having your big mouth yelling
up and down the balconies because you
seem to have a problem with the sound of
any language that ain't English but for
you to send your Neo-Nazi brother
barging outside my brother's door that's
another thing listen I listen you've
done plenty of talking it's time for you
to shut up and listen for once you
better start counting your lucky star
that you got Omar living next door cuz
one he's got enough respect for women
and for boundaries to never disrespect
you unlike George that petulent Manchild
you call a brother who couldn't help but
compare me to a bank robber today and
two and if you think you have it bad of
Omar trust me you do not want to have me
live with next door cuz I'll tell you
right now I want to take one second of
your rubbish so just keep yourself and
your psychotic family away from mine and
we won't have any more problems
understand
I understand
right oh my
wait I swear I didn't know my brother
was going to do all of that yeah we
tried to tell him to leave it but look I
just want to say I'm sorry about his
behavior there was an
overreaction sure
[Music]
can I
C Are you seriously buying that again
declin brother let me check for some C
why did you keep that
stuff hey D what are you
getting you know what just just take
it
sure an interes perspec this ites in I
think to the whole Nar around
thank I'll pay back for this I swear
in O Come here
listen your brother's been back for 10
years down in
Pentonville he's doing a job for us but
I guess now you're going to have to do
it what's the
job don't worry H you'll find out soon
[Music]
y who the hell was that from just lost
in it the hell is that all
about George
so did that say anything else George
honestly you did too much last
night excuse
me at the end of the day all he did was
give us a book it ain't like he bloody
baptized us whatever Muslims do and is
that what you
think and you really upset
arriet honestly George I can fight my
own battles I don't need some Macho Man
coming to fight and for me especially
when there's no need for that behavior
in the the first place you should have
just left me to
deal
George
wait um I just wanted to say I'm really
sorry
about about
everything my uncle wasn't always like
that but but nothing justifies his
actions and and I can disagree more with
his views I swear I've literally
disliked all of his videos
online it's all right you don't have
anything to be sorry
about I guess but still I'm
sorry my mom as well I a really nice
guy I don't know what a problem
is well maybe I
do was that all um actually um I was the
one reading the Quran om I gave us and
um I was wondering if I could have it
back and finish reading it I'll return
it when I'm
done it's not the same one but it's the
same thing has been for the last, 1400
100 years see I put tape over the cover
in case the non-muslim wants to read it
and doesn't want anyone else to know a
lot of reverts say I'm not a revert I
know I'm sorry I didn't mean it I just
mean you know I could understand why you
wouldn't want anyone to know like a lot
of the reverts I know do thank you Amir
I'm Harriet or Harry but call me Harriet
because I hate it when people call me
Harry don't know why I mention Harry
in case you have any questions about the
Quran or anything that's my email good
night
Harriet good night Amir and uh thanks
for the
book what is it now Stone I thought I
made myself clear when I generously
advised you to take a few days off yeah
the keyword being advise I decided not
to take that advice well turn up that
heid because here's another key word for
you compulsory as in compulsory leave of
absence excuse me the situation has got
out of hand now the media somehow have
become aware of your trouble with the
law
and we can't risk having you around here
until it all settles down are you
serious quite serious actually I know
you're used to doing whatever the hell
you like Omar but right now you don't
have that privilege you will not come
back to this school to teach until you
are told to return if you fail to comply
you will be terminated and what about my
students OH
police you're not the only one who can
teach English a level especially
considering the quality of your teaching
that you provide you're quite
replaceable that's excuse me mind do
nothing wrong we don't want some Supply
te we want all more Mr Ado I suggest you
advise that Elijah remove himself from
matters that don't concern him some
advice that you could certainly take
heed of yourself if you ask me and you
young man should watch that foul mouth
of yours it's earned you a week's
detention don't concern me and if you
fail to do so I shall have no choice but
to suspend you from the upcoming School
competitive basketball games until you
have learned how to respect those in
Authority do you
understand it's time to go Omar
[Music]
for
fore
or
[Music]
for
spee
[Music]
for
got got a
[Music]
om I was the
best I always run with you
man no matter what
[Music]
oh get off me get come come
how do you
feel it's it's fine I'm fine I don't
feel
nothing not the cut you
stupid I mean how's your heart
I can't believe
it I can't believe
it
this this all feels like a dream no a
nightmare that I can't get up
from he's dead
my best friend's dead and it's all over
something
stupid I'm sorry no no no no I must be
dreaming or losing my mind or something
I'll wake up I'll wake up tomorrow and
axel B my line get up let's go see the
day
I'm so sorry
a I could have stopped it I could have
prevented
it should no no I could have I could
have done more man I know
it instead act like an idiot and
what want some pay
beef what what kind of friend lets lets
his best friend do that man
I'm a worthless friend I'm a useless
friend and you know what it should be it
should be me lying out there lying out
there in the cold ground dead
oh my
servants have transgressed against
themselves and despare of the mercy of
Allah indeed Allah forgives all sins
indeed it's Allah who the forgiving the
merciful this feeling is not one that
anyone wishes to endure throughout their
life it's
tiring causes pain
and Destroy his
life but it's never ever too late to
change no matter how far you think you
have
stayed there is always a chance for
[Music]
Redemption here you go that'll be 50
lb thank you sir
call me
out oh
[Music]
listen I want you to keep your mouth
shut until I'm finished talking yeah
okay brother really screwed us getting
caught by the the feds now you're going
to do a little job for us that he was
meant to
do what a
job there's his freshy he's got a shop
down the road we offered to do some
business with him you know but the P
refused all he had to do is sit back and
let us do our team just like all these
other shop
owners we use his books to clear our
money and he gets a fast act for sitting
on his ass done but the son of took the
out of us he said no he disrespected us
so that's where you come
in you're going to go down to the shop
and you're going to finesse this guy
you're going to take all his money and
send a message make him bricks it's got
to be a no face thing yeah hey take this
broo what is that
bro I I can't use I've never shot anyone
before I can't be using them you're not
going to shoot the guy all right but he
ain't going to be scared of something
you so you're going to take this and
you're going to scare him with it it's
not even loaded stop being a little and
take this listen hun you ain't got to be
so shook here it's just for show will I
get paid for
this listen relax yeah EAS up you're
going to do this job for free and you
ain't going to complain about it either
you're listening do you know how much
Mula we lost cuz of your got brother you
think I'm playing with you listen relax
yeah relax I got it got
it so you're a greedy boy yeah I like
that still I can use
that cuz when you got people below you
who don't need nothing from you they
ain't going to do nothing for you just
like these little bags you do anything
for a bag now that's real
control listen yeah if you do a good job
then maybe you'll take your brother's
place then you're going to start making
some real peas for your
family what shop is it
[Music]
citizens
of members of the mlba mbba and citizens
of Britain the real citizens native
Britains
we are under attack it's such a tragedy
when people don't feel safe in their own
homes due to the indoctrination of the
Islamic
ideology well this tragedy is a
reality Omar sent
sadiki I need your
help imagine my absolute shock when I
recently read this headline Hackney six
form teacher Omar a taken in a
questioning by the
MI5 I had the displeasure of meeting
this Omar RI and let me tell you this
ain't a man who wants to integrate this
is a man who wants to indoctrinate to
mold the minds of our children I urge
you to understand the severity of this
situation they are let in a known
criminal a man wanted by the flipping
MI5 to teach our
children these people are violent
they're aggressive in their approach
they don't want peace they don't want to
make an honest life here they don't want
to work hard for their place in this
great nation they just want to take take
and
take and what are we left with nothing
when are we going to stand up as a
nation and say in enough is
enough what's next it's time to fight
back go back there and just give me your
money what are you all talking about
just get behind the c just give me your
money it's time to take a stand against
these criminals before it's too
late before we lose our great country to
to a backwards
ideology cuz if we don't we not only
risk losing our home and our land but we
risk losing our
families so I'm calling to you I'm
calling for your
help cuz if we don't we're in
trouble divided we are conquered oh my
God he but together
we are
invincible it's us or
them what will you stand for are you
just going to sit back and allow our
country to be taken over by these evil
Invaders okay Al just stay with me okay
I'm going to call an ambulance hello yes
I need an ambulance please I'm at ow
shop in
haggon he's been shot please hurry up
he's lost a lot of blood Al it's okay
you're going to be okay all right
right or will you stand with me and the
mlba and help us make London British
again let's put the great back into
Britain
[Music]
Omar e
for
[Music]
a
he for
[Music]
all for